it's been 13 years since the original
Avatar was a sequel worth the wait
here's what critics had to say no movie
completes everybody but enough people
anyway that's my explanation Avatar the
way of water the first of several
planned follow-ups to James Cameron's
2009 Mega hits is nearly here the
original film was not only one of the
biggest box office success stories ever
but it was also a pioneering
accomplishment in visual effects and 3D
filmmaking the early social media
reactions to the hotly anticipated
sequel offers some glowing Praise of
Cameron's latest visual feat but now
that the official review embarga was
lifted what are Critics on Rotten
Tomatoes saying about the way of water
after all the Cinematic landscape has
changed quite a bit since the first
avatar was released and 2009 almost
seems like another era entirely entries
from franchises like Marvel and DC have
been dominating the Blockbuster movie
landscape which may leave many curious
about how Cameron's original Vision will
fare but based on the reviews that have
come in so far it seems that audiences
who were blown away by the first trip to
Pandora will be more than happy with
this long-awaited sequel why do you come
to us
my family's safe as of the making of
this video Avatar the way of water
boasts of Rotten Tomatoes Tomato Meter
score of 85 percent that's by not being
a plus but that early average score
still puts it on track to be a
certifiable critical success and as of
now the sequel boasts a better critical
reception than the original Avatar which
logged into an 82 percent critic score
when it all was said and done for many
reviewers a sense of wonder and all felt
in the first film is very much present
in its sequel according to the
Atlantic's David Sims for the way of
water the decadence is more than enough
for Cinemas that have been starved of
authentic spectacle finally here's a
gorgeous three-course meal of it the
features epic scope and non-sub visual
Splendor have been mentioned in several
glowing reviews of the movie
entertainment Weekly's Leah Greenblatt
also pointed out the Grandeur of the
film by writing a meticulous World
building as astonishing and enveloping
as anything we've ever seen on screen
until that Crown is passed inevitably in
December 2024 the projected release date
for Avatar 3. similarly in his review
for the Chicago Sun Times Richard Roper
declared Avatar the way of water is such
a screen-popping visual Feast it earns a
three-hour 12 minute running time Roper
also went on to add that Pandora remains
one of the most amazing worlds we've
ever seen on the big screen while many
reviewers assessments have been positive
there are some middling critical takes
amongst all the praise I need you
with me
and I need you to be strong
when Avatar was released not all film
reviewers were over the moon with praise
for what will become a planned Saga
about Pandora and the response to Avatar
the way of water is no different while
many reviewers were transported by the
grandiose visual World building others
were left cold by the plots and
characters Kyle Anderson of the Nerdist
said of the film it's a gorgeous visual
treat a testament to the Artistry and
attention to detail of Cameron and his
effects crew but if you're looking for
anything else from it you'll be left
sorely disappointed meanwhile mashables
cresty pochko node said that the thinly
written characters didn't live up to the
technology used to bring the actors
performances to life well poachko had
praised for certain aspects of the film
she ultimately concluded Cameron loses
track of his characters Snell's his
story squanders has star power and then
Dizzy's 3D audiences of so much whiz
bang that they might feel attacked in
lieu of odd for some critics like the
Guardians Peter Bradshaw The film's
Narrative detail simply did not come
together in a satisfying way he observed
the floatingly Bland plot is like a
children's story without the humor a why
a story without the emotional wound an
action thriller without the hard edge of
real excitement still even with these
mid-linked negative reviews taken into
account the overall assessment from
critics appear to be the Avatar The Way
of water it's a worthy successor to the
original and another stunning visual
accomplishment from James Cameron if you
got any more send them in always happy
to talk about Avatar
[Music]